Ukrainian soldiers are reuniting
with family
and friends
after the eight month
long Russian occupation.
The people of Arizona Zone
are celebrating
the liberation of their cities,
singing patriotic songs and crying.
Climbing to the tops of buildings
to hoist the Ukrainian flag.
But her son is facing
challenging mandatory conditions.
Large parts of the city
are without electricity
and running water.
There are also reports
of landmines
and other hazards
left behind by Russian troops.
But Zelinski says
efforts are now being made
to return the city to normalcy.
Here's what he told the G-20 summit.
That was earlier this morning.
Watch Vietnam.
Pretty glad
It is like, for example, D-Day,
the landing of the allies in Normandy.
It was not yet
a final point in the fight against evil,
but it already determined
the entire further course of events.
If the victory will be ours in any case,
and we are sure of it,
then shouldn't
we try to implement our formula for peace
to save thousands of lives
and protect the world from
further destabilization?
Zielinski also outlining a peace proposal
which includes the end
to nuclear threats,
more food and energy security,
prisoner swaps
and a full withdrawal by Russia.
Is this the beginning
of the end of the war?
As President Zelensky says,
let's discuss now.
I want to bring in CNN's
chief international correspondent
Chris Award.
Good morning to you there. How.
How significant is Zelensky's
proposed peace plan to the G20
Well, I would have to say
it is obviously coming from a place of
buoyancy and exuberance
after the taking of Harrison
or the liberation of Hair Salon,
the demands are maximalist.
There isn't a huge amount
in this ten point
peace plan
that the Russians
are likely to say, okay,
we have something we can start with here.
So it's not
that the demands are sort of outlandish
in any way.
They really make a lot of sense,
and they pertain
to hugely important issues
that affect the whole world,
like food security, energy security,
nuclear security, as well as demanding
that Russia withdraw its forces
and that there be
a cessation of hostilities.
But in terms of how realist it is
to get the Russians
to come to the negotiating table
and use this as a starting draft,
that is probably more of a long shot
because the Russians
will obviously be wanting
to see more extractions
or at least some concessions
that they can take away.
At this stage, though, guys,
I don't think that the Ukrainians
have any interest
in making those concessions. Right.
And that's that's critical to all of this
as the winter comes. Right.
Which could completely change the game.
And President Biden
is meeting with world
leaders at the G20,
hoping to really get them aligned.
Can something significant
come out of the G20
that would really aid Ukraine at
this point in this, Clarissa?
It's a really
tough one, Poppy, honestly,
because at the end of the day,
what you're hearing from U.S.
officials, we've heard some in the U.S.
military say, you know,
now's the time for Ukraine
to really take stock and sit down
and think about what a peace plan or what
some kind of a negotiated settlement
would look like.
Other officials in the U.S.
administration are saying
that's really not our place in the US
or in the White House
to be dictating to the Ukrainians
what the terms should look like
or when they should sit down
Ukraine right
now, understandably,
is not in the mood to negotiate.
They've lost too much.
They've just taken back her son.
This is a huge strategic
and symbol
like humiliation for the Russians.
It was the only regional capital
and the largest city that they've taken
since the beginning
of the invasion back in February.
At the same time,
while you have silenced
you talking about D-Day
and saying that it's clear
the trajectory of the war in the sense
that the Russians can't win.
President Putin also understands
for his own political survival,
he can't lose.
And so what
the Russians are banking on at this stage
is that they can drag out
or protract this conflict
as long as they can
and make it as painful as they can.
Not just for the Ukrainians,
but for the Western countries
that are backing Ukraine.
And as you head into the winter,
as you head into a recession,
they're hoping that that will sort of,
you know,
push the Ukrainians,
that there will be more
sort of Ukraine supporters in the West
pushing them
to go to the negotiating table.
But at this stage,
I don't see that happening overnight.
And of course,
we're also we're seeing such triumphant
voices, reaction coming out of her song
where it's been a long eight months
for these Ukrainians so far.
But we're also getting
a better picture of the torture
and the hell that they have been
living through
in this Russian occupation.
That's right.
And it's
such an important thing,
I think, Caitlin,
to underscore for our viewers,
this is victory and victory
as you can see in those scenes of
jubilation is a beautiful thing.
But it's also grim
because it is also now
the beginning
of the sort
of unpacking
of the trauma of the horrors
of what happened, of people
who were tortured, who were beaten.
One man
allegedly for just spray painting,
you know, glory
be to Ukraine on a bus stop.
So the people of Harrison,
many of them have lived through things
that are unthinkable
and they are now living in a city
that has had no electricity,
that probably won't have electricity
for several more months.
And they're going into a winter
that promises
to be
brutally cold,
as the winter often
is under continued bombardment, strategic
targeting
of Ukraine's critical
civilian infrastructure.
And so while this is a moment
for Ukraine to celebrate,
it is still painful
and there are still
many challenges ahead.